-Welcome back.
-Thanks, Jimmy.
-It is so good to see you.
You look fantastic.
-Thanks.
-You know, I have talked to you
about a lot of things,
but I saw you posted over
the weekend --
You were at "SNL" with Tony Hawk
here and Amy Poehler.
-Yeah.
I didn't know you guys
were pro skaters.
-I know.
-Yeah, it was good to know.
-Isn't that something?
A lot of people don't know that
about Amy and I,
but we spend most of
our time doing, you know,
skateboarding stuff.
-Were you there just for fun
or to see the gang
or so -- Aubrey.
-Got to support Aubrey,
the baby.
-The baby was great.
-Gotta support the baby,
who crushed.
-She did.
You crushed when you hosted,
by the way.
-Oh!
-Yes, you crushed!
-These are crushers.
-You crushed!
-We go in and we crush.
-You know to how to do it!
-But we talked right before
you were about to host,
and you were kind of like,
"Dude,
I'm so excited about this."
-Yeah, and you told me to
pull out, remember?
-Yeah, I said --
-You were like, "Baby, baby."
-I said, "Hey, cancel.
They'll get somebody else."
-"You take the money, pull out."
But I did it anyway.
-Yeah, you did.
-I don't listen.
-Yeah. You're a rebel.
-I think maybe that was
the greatest week of my life.
-You think so?
-Yeah, Baby Freddie and Maya.
-You got to play with everybody.
-Yes.
-You were so good,
like a natural.
But then you went back, too.
-Oh, I know.
I got a Bat-Signal call to be
"Hello Kitty" with Keke.
-Yeah.
That's a rite of passage as
a New Yorker, to get that call.
-I want to ask you
about something.
-Okay. I know you recently --
You had that amnesia thing
come up, so you just go slow.
-Yeah, I hit my head
before the show,
and I don't remember who I am.
-Yeah, just do your own pace.
-So that's my question.
-Yes, dear?
-Who am I?
-Yeah. Listen --
-Who am I to you, though,
seriously?
-Jimmy, on the deepest level,
who are any of us, you feel me?
-Wow!
-That's right.
-Let me take a hit of that.
-The thing is --
If you guys want some of this.
-Yeah. Come on.
-But, like,
what are we doing here?
Where are we? Midtown?
-I have a real serious
question here
and I want to know -- I want to
get down to the nitty-gritty.
-Okay, my dear.
-Are you --
You have a new hobby.
Is this true?
And what I'm hearing --
Do you know where I'm going?
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I guess word is spreading.
So, in addition to
the skateboarding,
you know, in a new year,
you want to reflect.
You want to consider,
"Who am I?"
-"What is this?"
-I decided -- I thought --
I think my
whole personality was bad.
-That's unbelievable.
I've never heard of that.
-You know what I mean?
What am I doing with New York
and the cigarettes?
Enough. So I became a surfer.
And I think maybe --
-You became a surfer.
-Yeah.
-In my whole life,
I never would've thought
Natasha Lyonne would surf.
And we've known each other
since 1990-something.
And -- The first time we met,
Kurt Cobain was there.
-That's right.
-And you -- But how did you
even get into surfing?
What do you do?
Aren't you nervous?
-Well, I Googled
"mid-life crisis."
And I --
-Ah, exactly. I do it every day.
-So, I thought,
"I think I'll take this one."
And, you know, make me, like,
a Buddhist or something.
"I'm too into quantum physics,
I should be more into nature,"
I said to myself.
-Wow!
So this makes you more Zen.
-Yes. And now I'm, like --
I get up all the time.
I know I don't seem it,
but I'm quite spry.
And I go out there --
-You're up
and you're on the board.
-I'm out there.
And it's very hard.
You can't -- It's hard to
light up if you're on the board.
-Yeah.
-So it's very helpful,
just as a tip
for anyone struggling to quit.
-You want to quit smoking,
just start surfing.
-That's the ticket.
-That's the way to do it.
-It's been great. Yeah.
-I can't believe
that you're doing this.
This is so cool.
-Yeah.
-And you're going to continue
to do this?
-I think that's who I am now.
Yeah, basically. Yeah.
-That's --
You're a complete surfer now?
-That's just --
Yeah, that's who I am.
New show,
new personality, you know?
-Well, what about the old show?
What about "Russian Doll"?
-"Russian Doll"
is still in the mix.
So, "Russian Doll" -- But that's
when I'm going to do --
-That's not surfing Natasha.
-Yeah, but that's -- It is.
It is.
-It is now?
-Yeah. You know, like,
string theory, surfing.
It's a different kind.
-Ooh.
-Yeah, you got to surf
a different kind of a wave.
You see?
-Wow! Ooh!
-Yeah, but --
-This is so deep.
-I know. Life is heavy.
-Yeah.
-You know, we all die,
so it's nuts.
-Yeah, no, don't get that deep.
"Russian Doll."
-Oh, not us.
-No, not us.
-I meant everyone else.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, don't panic. Yes, dear?
-With my plastic surgeon,
I don't die.
Yeah, of course. Hello.
-By the way, you look so good.
-Thank you so much.
-You are honestly so good.
-Yeah.
-Do I look like mid-50s?
-No.
I would say -- I thought --
See, if you're 27,
that makes me like 22, which...
Yeah. As I always say,
not a day over 1.
That's how you look.
-I appreciate that.
But, so, "Russian Doll" --
we're not sure
when that's coming back.
-I got to write it.
I got to clone myself.
I don't know if
the science is there.
I got a lot of projects.
-You got a lot of projects.
-If I don't direct three movies
before it's over,
I'll have a bad "All That Jazz"
moment looking back, so...
-You think so?
-Yeah, I got to set myself up.
This is -- You know,
you've got to feel like
a narrow window as an artist.
You got to get it all in before
they take it away from you.
That's show biz. It's --
-Do you want to direct?
Do you want to direct?
-Yeah.
Yeah, I did all that directing
on "Russian Doll,"
and I loved it.
And --
-I could -- I love this.
-Yeah, it makes me so happy.
It's really --
It's a joy in my life.
-So we're going to see some
Natasha Lyonne-directed movies.
-Yeah, "pictures,"
I'm gonna call them.
-Yeah, "pictures!"
That's what I'm talking about.
I would love that.
-Yeah.
-Oh, you've got to
come back for that.
I will support that all the way.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Let's talk about "Poker Face."
-Let's get to business.
-"Poker Face."
-Yeah.
-It's on Peacock.
And if you don't have Peacock,
get it.
It's a fantastic service.
-It's -- Yeah.
This show is excellent.
It's Rian Johnson.
I mean, it's excellent.
-Oh, I thought you meant
my show.
I was going to say,
"Thank you so much."
-Oh, by the way,
this show is also great.
-Thank you. I appreciate it.
Rian Johnson created it.
-Yeah.
-No, but Rian Johnson also
created your show, "Poker Face."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-We know Rian Johnson
from, recently --
-As the director of...
-"Knives Out."
-...this show.
-And, of course,
"The Tonight Show,"
as well, yeah.
Rian and I go way back.
-And he got an
Academy Award nomination
this morning for "Glass Onion."
-Not too shabby.
Congrats, Rian Johnson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Seem like a fun --
-This is a mensch of a guy.
-He seems like a fun individual.
-A genuine genius.
I mean -- You know, we talk
a lot about the crossword.
I can only do the Thursday.
He does Friday, Saturday
no problem.
-You do Thursday? Really?
-Oh, I do Thursdays.
And -- Oh, also Hong Chau
and Stephanie Hsu
were nominated this morning,
and they're guest stars in it.
They're awesome.
-By the way, the guest stars
on "Poker Face" --
-Bananas.
-The guest stars on your show
is kind of insane.
-Yeah.
-Can we go through some of them?
-Sure, sure.
-Chloe Sevigny.
-Aw, that's my buddy.
That's my sister.
-She's the best.
-Yeah.
-I love that she's in it.
Who else showed up in it?
Who's your --
Who's the villain in this?
-Oh, we got Benjamin Bratt.
-Benjamin Bratt
is fantastic in this.
-A gem of a human being. Yeah.
-Who else showed up?
There's, like --
-We got Adrien Brody.
Nick Nolte
is in the episode I --
-Nick Nolte is the best.
-Yeah.
-I go, "How did --"
-I directed that episode.
Directed Nolte, baby.
-Yes! Come on, baby!
Directing Nick Nolte!
-Yeah.
-It's so good.
-Judith Light.
It just goes --
Joseph Gordon-Levitt.
I mean, it's on and on.
-Joseph Gordon -- I know --
-Lil Rel.
I mean, it's an incredible cast.
-They do it because
they love you.
-Aww!
-As we all do.
Yeah, we would do
anything for you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Surfing or not surfing.
-Yeah.
-But how do we describe
"Poker Face" besides
high octane?
-Yeah.
Well, everything is high octane.
-Everything is high octane.
-Well, it's sort of a throwback.
It's almost like
a '70s sort of --
It's if Columbo made a baby with
The Hulk and Magnum P.I.
and the Angela Lansbury.
-Yeah, that's exactly right.
-But it looks, because of Rian,
almost like
"California Split"
or "The Long Goodbye."
You know, those '70s Altmans.
I mean, it's gorgeous.
-Yeah.
-And it's just really cool.
So, it's like
brand-new sort of throwback
and it's a real
Case of the Week mystery,
beautifully crafted
puzzle box each week.
You can watch it with
your children
and also your grandparents.
I'm still talking.
-I love it.
-Yeah.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Natasha Lyonne in
"Poker Face."
Take a look at this.
-Now, you might say
that's impossible.
The door was
locked from the inside,
but that's where the
cinnamon floss comes into play.
-Right. Cinnamon floss.
I guess I'm not over
the part where
you're a human lie detector.
-Yeah, I know,
it's, uh -- it's crazy, but --
-My favorite color is yellow.
-[ Chuckles ]
Bull[bleep]
-I grew up in Old Dime Box.
-Bull[bleep]
-I grew up in Tanglewood.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Wow!
You ever gamble?
'Cause you could make a killing.
-[ Laughs ]
Nah.
-Come on! That's how you do it!
Come on! The baby!
Natasha Lyonne -- "Poker Face"
premieres this Thursday
on Peacock.
Nate Bargatze
joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Natasha!